my guest tonight starred in The Hangover
movies and the Emmy award-winning series
the office he's beloved please welcome
our pal Ed Helms Edie nice to see you
sir
great to see you thanks for saluting me
even though I'm not in the military I
your my captain you're you're you're
still my captain I'm gonna ask you the
question that is most on my mind which
is here in LA you know things are
starting to they're trying to relax
things a little bit are you able to to
get outside the house because that's the
only way to stay sane if you can be
responsible but still get outside
somehow I can't I live in a neighborhood
that is very conducive to walking and
that sort of thing there's a lot of face
mask shaming going on you know if people
aren't wearing face masks then yeah yeah
real dirty looks and the dirty looks are
even dirtier when they're from behind
the mask because it's just eyes it's
more intense but I actually support that
I support shaming non face mask wear
because someone could like sneeze and
kill your family so like let's just all
be responsible here it's one thing if
someone doesn't want to practice social
distancing themselves but there are
people that will invade your space yes
they're willfully getting into someone
else's grill which seems weird yeah I'm
kind of a leave me alone guy in and on
and on a normal day and at this point
it's like yeah everybody just better
back off yeah yeah I'm saying
don't you feel a little close yeah no I
think I'm too close right now yeah
you're freaking me out okay you guys
close as I want and this is eight this
is HD baby I'm smearing pure
but you can feel the anxiety you know
even when you're just you know walking
around socially distance if you see
other people you can sense there's a lot
of tension out there yeah and I think I
just think everybody everybody's sort of
baseline anxiety is a little bit higher
right now I was out for a walk and there
was a guy in this in this sort of grassy
area doing yoga like it looked like he
probably did yoga videos for people like
he's an incredible physique he just had
little tiny shorts and was doing these
poses and it was it was like kind of
amazing then he starts he kind of takes
this meditation pose and really sinks
into this deep state of meditation or
relaxation or something and I was like
pant this is awesome I wish I could kind
of like have that much peace during this
crazy time we wound up walking back to
our car in this parking lot and there's
no cars in this parking lot except for
ours and then his and he he walks past
us goes to his car as we're sitting
there another car comes into this empty
parking lot and pulls in right next to
him which during this time is kind of a
weird move right like there's plenty of
other places to park yeah the parking
space is point anywhere so this guy
pulls in right next to hit the Zen
masters car he sees this and he goes
[Laughter]
maybe you're not quite as at peace as I
thought I feel better when I find it
that the Zen guy's totally lose it
completely is it my wife and I just
burst out laughing and we started don't
drive home we were going to cut now my
daughter who is two and a half years old
internalized that it she says it all the
time so it'll be like alright come on we
got to put your shoes on
that's what she took away from the Zen
master yeah exactly
you know it's freaking me out a little
bit is I know it's a nice thing and I
hear at a certain time at night you can
hear people cheering for the medical
workers great it's great I love the
sentiment of it and I think it's really
beautiful but yes if do you know what
I'm saying here it is great I've even
heard from friends in the medical
community that are like it makes us feel
so good and appreciate it and and that's
amazing but I do have this quick little
mm like me my first response when I
first hear that all that the horns and
like my neighborhood goes berserk people
are beating drums and yelling and
honking horns and stuff and for that
first like half a second my first
thought is oh my god the purge has
started yes it's like the social order
has just broken down and we have to like
run to the basement and and try to save
ourselves and maybe start eating a
neighbor or something I hear that and I
think Sambi apocalypse it sounds like a
horde of monsters are coming now I've
seen footage in Italy they sing opera
they do this stuff here in America we
shriek and we bang on kettles and pots
and it just scares the [ __ ] out of me
and I'm I'm really happy for the Met it
mean I'm very I want them medical
workers to get their due but I feel like
there should be a better way like we
should there must be a better way to
show our appreciation like just quietly
mail them checks maybe that's the way to
go yeah it also wakes up my two and a
half year old almost Ellery know oh
that's wrong
yeah I forgot I'll buy it so that's not
ideal I would think of you have a two
and a half year old you're probably
doing fun things with her her is that
right lots of games lots of songs and
stuff I built a we'd be getting too much
cardboard
from all of our deliveries so I
repurposed some cardboard into a train
that I made a poor train I made a
cardboard train for my daughter Wow how
now is this just like okay I'll put one
box in front of another and that's the
engine and this is the caboose right and
I'm knowing you I'm guessing it got a
little more elaborate yeah so I'm kind
of crafty a little bit of a craft nerd
and I got I got too into it I'm just
gonna admit it my wife kept saying
exactly what you just said she would be
fine with two boxes next to each other
and I was like yeah but that that's I'm
not okay with that and so I put a lot of
hours this thing and it became clearly
my own sort of coping mechanism as much
as something for my daughter or so so
wait I mean how detailed is this thing
first of all how big is it well it's a
fully working coal powered locomotive a
coal powered cardboard em engine that's
that's problematic and have you fired it
up yet no I'm scared too honestly but I
know it'll work if I do at least for a
couple of seconds but no it's it's
fairly big you know it's a child's train
that she can get inside of and pretend
like she's a choo-choo engineer but you
know what's gonna happen it starts that
way I once built a train for my son and
he started out going choo-choo and then
within months he went on strike
commanded he demanded different hours he
invoked all kind of federal acts did he
he tied me up in the courts the train
never ran on time it lost money so I'm
just telling you this is what's coming
as your child gets older
you're also a fine musician and
I can see instruments behind you you're
very very good banjo player do you think
your daughter has the gene well she she
yeah she loves to play I got actually
this little thing is a it's called a
piccolo banjo it's a tiny it's like a
ukulele sized banjo and this thing is
actually this is really cool this is
actually from turn-of-the-century I
think this was made in 1903 so it's a
Wow it's a very it's a valuable vintage
instrument but I let my 2 year old can I
hear a little
[Music]
like I feel like a giant well of course
the neck would be really hard to play
I would guess because it's everything so
compressed that sounded great I love the
the the tone it's so blinky and
optimistic you know it's a happy little
instrument and like I said I probably
shouldn't let my daughter play with it
but it's just I I'm just I don't want to
be precious about it I want her yeah I
felt the same way my my daughter when
she was about your daughter's age we
just let her play with a Ming Vaz he
smashed it and we were out well it was
about six million dollars but she
learned a love of pottery yeah I think
that's more important you precious about
these things let's talk about the
whiskey sour
happy hour because this is a great great
idea i co-founded this thing called the
bluegrass situation calm which is
basically a online hub for roots
Americana music and culture and a
platform for a lot of musicians and and
our executive director Amy right now or
and I were just brainstorming as soon as
this lockdown happens I think like a lot
of people we were just feeling like
there's this big terrible tragedy going
on but also because we're on lockdown
there's this feeling of impotence like
how can we do anything to help yeah and
so this idea just emerged well let's so
let's just leverage all of our resources
and friendships and relationships within
the music biz and all these great
artists and and put this variety show
together it's just a fun way to hang out
you can put it on in the background and
listen to the music well if we have a
quip here from whiskey sour happy hour
let's show that right now let's take a
look
where the people say y'all sing a song
with a friend change the shape that I'm
in get back at the game start playing
again I wanted to get to one thing
before we go which is I heard that you
had been in contact with the other cast
members of the office yeah it's really
been nice there's just a text Shane that
that started up I think somebody had
just sort of a question for everyone
early on and and then of course everyone
just started jumping in with memes and
jokes and comments and it's been really
nice there's something very nostalgic
and I mean a lot of us are in touch
anyway but just to have everybody kind
of riffing at the time it's it's it's
really really cool this pandemic has
brought a lot of people closer together
ironically we're distanced but we're
communicating a lot more now we are
calling up friends we haven't talked to
in a long time we're zooming people so
it's nice to think of the cast of the
office is no different you guys are all
just pinging each other back and forth
yeah you know I hear so often from fans
how much that show means to them and
what a comfort it is to them and that of
course means so much to me but I also I
share that with them right it's it's
something that for all of us that were
involved in making that show it was it
was an incredible time it was like a
just a magical time and work we all have
deep nostalgia for it not just the
episodes as they turned out but the
actual community causes yeah making that
show and it just was there were no bad
apples it was an incredible cast you
know so many of the cast to that show
they're just wonderful wonderful people
[Music]
no not a good guy well pain in the ass
I'm gonna say about a third of you
really good people and the rest absolute
monsters and you know what I'm talking
about
cuz you're one of them because you're
one of the monsters the only one saying
how wonderful everyone is whenever ed
Helms is saying it was just not a bad
apple in the group you know he's the bad
apple yeah he's the one let me make sure
I get the word out that you got a watch
whiskey sour happy hour every Wednesday
okay this is from April 22nd to May 13th
at the bluegrass situation calm on bgs
facebook and youtube it's also a
fundraiser so that we're raising money
for two incredible organizations music
cares and Direct Relief so and the
donate buttons are active terrific good
the duration too so so enjoy the show
and also give some money to some great
causes very good ed you're a you're a
very fine fellow I will say that about
you you're talented but you're also
you're very kind and nice and stand-up
gentlemen so I doff my imaginary cap to
you I really do
and I salute you in a quasi-military
fashion because not military you just
use two fingers so I think I think that
means I'm a Girl Scout yeah hey thank
you very much for doing this and be well
and enjoy your time with your family of
course thank you so much Conan it's
always great to see you
Cheers another salute